man hat gehört dass die polizei mit
dieser enormen gewaltbereitschaft nicht
gerechnet hat jetzt werden aber stimmen
laut dass es schon irgendwelche
anzeichen gab was weißt du konnte man
eigentlich mit dieser tat doch rechnen
müssen also die anzeichen in den
vergangenen wochen waren sicherlich da
es gab immer wieder vorfälle im
stadtgebiet an den wochenenden wo zb
einmal eine größere gruppe vor dem
polizeirevier 1 in der innenstadt war
und gerufen hat ganz stuttgart hast die
polizei
es war einer der vorfälle erst vor zwei
wochen dann auf dem kleinen schlossplatz
unweit der stelle wo dieses mal die
eskalation begann waren schon einmal
mehrere hundert leute die dort gefeiert
haben im bereich des schlossplatzes bis
die polizei dann eingeschritten ist und
den kleinen schlossplatz geräumt hat
also ein polizist sagte mir heute morgen
man hat sicherlich die entwicklung sehen
können warum man trotz dessen nicht
vorbereitet was hätte man besser machen
können wenn man eigentlich wusste da
waren sich etwas sehr dramatisches an
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man wusste
dass ich eine so dramatische eskalation
anbahnt entwickelt ich glaube mit dem
hat auch die polizei ist sicherlich
nicht rechnen können
ausgangslage war ja dass ein 17 jähriger
im schlossgarten am eckensee
kontrolliert werden sollte und sich dann
eine große gruppe von ungefähr
nachher 500 leuten es solle der
solidarisiert hat und gegen die polizei
und gegen die sachen hier in der
innenstadt vorgegangen ist ich glaube
damit konnte wirklich keiner rechnen
allerdings sagen
polizeibeamte unter der hand natürlich
auch man hätte tatsächlich schärfer
gegen diese gruppierungen vorgehen
müssen
vorfeld um ein zeichen zu setzen viele
der beteiligten jetzt kommen offenbar
gar nicht aus stuttgart sondern sind am
wochenende eben hier in die stadt
gekommen
und weil es hier eben geduldet wurde
welche ist richtig erkennen kann stehst
du vor dem gerber in stuttgarter sieht
es ja im hintergrund schon wieder nach
belebten alltag aus ist er wirklich
schon wieder eingekehrt oder sind die
menschen in stuttgart noch besorgt und
verängstigt ich glaube der alltag bei
den kunden und jahr flanieren hier in
der innenstadt der ist schon wieder
eingekehrt ganz anders bei den
einzelhändlern die hier wirklich mit
massiven schäden zu kämpfen haben mit
großem schaufensterfronten mit die jetzt
verbarrikadiert sind und mit großen
holzplatten das thw hatte den ganzen
sonntag gebraucht um die schäden zu
beseitigen und die
einzelhandelsgeschäfte zu sichern
natürlich auch gegen plünderungen die
teilweise in der nacht schon
stattgefunden haben
bei den einzelhändlern ist definitiv
noch keine normalität eingekehrt und sie
wird auch in den nächsten wochen nicht
einkehren denn so eine scheibe ist nicht
mal schnell im baumarkt gekauft sondern
das sind meistens maßanfertigungen die
von knapper reihen spezielle produziert
werden das dauert wochen bis die
geliefert werden können und bis dahin
müssen sich die geschäfte daneben
behelfen morgens die holzplatte weg und
abends wieder hin